io prima o poi parlo con l'avvocato e
faccio scrivere una lettera al sindaco
perché dobbiamo dire basta ai vestiti
come regali durante le feste
nonostante tu alla persona glielo dici
mi raccomando non mi regalare i vestiti
perché tanto non ha idea di quale sia il
mio gusto è nemmeno la taglia visto che
se sbagli quella c'è qualcuno che
potrebbe anche piangere perché poi mi
costringi a ridere per finta
semplicemente perché non si può fare
altrimenti perché l'unica alternativa
sarebbe mandarvi a cagare ma non si può
fare ma ancor peggio dei vestiti come
regalo ci sono quei regali che cercano
di avvicinarsi a quelli che sono i tuoi
interessi ma falliscono miseramente tipo
quelle nonne anzianissimi che dopo una
certa età dovrebbero soltanto le care
buste con dentro soldi da darti durante
qualsiasi tipo di festa ma che invece di
fare quello vanno a chiedere ai tuoi
genitori ma che interessi al mio
nipotino e loro magari rispondono i
videogiochi oi film e diamo quindi il
benvenuto a quel tipo di regali che
nessuno sa da dove cazzo sbuchino fuori
in particolare sto parlando dei dvd game
quelli che appunto soltanto una persona
che non ha idea di cosa sia né un film
nel videogioco ti potrebbe regalare per
chi non sapesse cosa sono i dvd game i
dvd game sono ormai erano dei giochi che
si potevano giocare in dvd nati
praticamente agli inizi degli anni 2000
quando c'è stato il boom dei lettori dvd
e che si potevano giocare con tutta la
famiglia con il semplice ausilio di un
telecomando parecchio sporco anche e
come erano questi dvd game la merda come
potresti mai immaginati diversamente
questi abbiamo tv di game come chi vuol
esser milionario il primo gioco in dvd
in italia è divertentissimo perché i
soldi non li vinci per davvero e quindi
mi chiedo che sa ke kazzo serva serate
di puro divertimento questa è una palese
bugia
poi abbiamo un altro tipo di dvd
interattivo che più che giochi sono veri
e propri corsi per esempio della
ballerina il lago dei cigni dvd con 30
minuti di lezioni di ballo interattive
cosa cazzo vorrà dire lezioni di ballo
interattivo e poi è tra l'altro ben 30
minuti
elezioni è praticamente come matrix
ficcano dei floppy e dopo dieci minuti
sa il kung fu e questo fortunatamente a
me non interessa mi vorrei invece
soffermare su un paio di dvd game molto
particolari come primo abbiamo niente il
popolo di meghni che twilight seen it
like che vuol dire visto seen it
previsto e nel finn nel senso scena it
twilight
e come se non bastasse include un
miniposter il omaggio me lo farà
autografate da bram stoker e quindi come
il gioco che tra l'altro si può giocare
anche su pc questa meraviglia è
semplicemente una serie di domande a cui
dovrà rispondere a volte ti farà vedere
una scena e tu dovrà indovinare delle
cose particolari e siccome ho visto i
film di twilight questa è la scena dove
arriva al camioncino e lui la ferma con
la mano in modo molto figo e molto
virile ci siamo bagnati tutti a vederla
domanda quindi è chi guidava il
camioncino che cazzo ne so chi guida
vuoi capire come faccio a saperlo apple
e altre come ho detto prima sono
semplicissime domande due cose mi hanno
incuriosito 1 e che ci siano due
modalità di gioco gioco e gioco
flessibile devo riprendere in mano i dvd
delle ballerine che devo fare
no gioco flessibile intende soltanto che
puoi scegliere il numero di domande che
ti faranno
un'altra cosa che qualcuno con l'occhio
di falco probabilmente ha già notato è
che il gioco è fatto dalla konami sai no
tra un metal gear e un silent hill e ci
voleva giustamente una pausa e tra
l'altro il gioco e che gli 12 quindi si
sono bruciati il 99 per cento del loro
pubblico
il secondo devo di game che voglio farvi
vedere oggi è missione 3d game over che
se lo ricorda questo film manco io ma
nella collector's edition di questo film
possiamo trovare due dvd praticamente
questi due dvd abbiamo sia il film che
il gioco nel dvd 2 abbiamo il film è il
gioco in 2d ma nel dvd un abbiamo sia il
film sia il gioco in 3d fico è il futuro
dei videogiochi è qui
da dubitare e mica solo un paio di
occhiali ma ben quattro questa è una
cosa [ __ ] per esempio il gioco in
questione è megan race
ve lo ricordate il lion cro fiction
c'era appunto il leone della lion che
guidava un carrello tutto fatto al
computer molto molto figo e c'era
qualcuno da casa che telefonava e doveva
premere i tasti per farlo girare a
destra sinistro abbassarsi alzarsi il
gioco di missione 3d game over è
esattamente la stessa cosa devi premere
destra e sinistra sul telecomando quando
se lo dice volevo farvelo vedere almeno
vedevamo come andava avanti no sempre
nello stesso punto
cazzo ma il pt è praticamente
impossibile ma com'è che sbatte sempre
lo stesso punto a un certo punto avevo
fatto un test io ho iniziato a sbagliare
di proposito gli ostacoli per vedere
altre scene di incidenti eccomi a
sorpresa li schivava in automatico
esattamente tutto quel pezzo lì dove io
per 10 volte ho premuto i tasti per
schivare gli ostacoli non è servito a
nulla perché lì schivava in automatico e
credo che il momento in cui ci sia
l'incidente è lì che devi iniziare a
premere i tasti ma nonostante io li
prema alla perfezione non funziona
quindi io ad occhio buttato mezz'ora
della mia vita prossimo gioco jurassic
park explorer il gioco sui dinosauri per
tutta la famiglia è sempre per tutta la
famiglia sempre per per gli italiani
medi
scegli fra gioco corto o lungo o le
mozioni volano per prima cosa è tutto
completamente doppiato in italiano torna
a isola torna con un gioco unico nel suo
genere
jurassic park in explorer non so perché
dopo aver finito il lavoro
nessuno mi ha voluto pagare non mi hanno
voluto dire il perchè c'è dimmi se non è
figo che il menu principale l'entrata
del jurassic park come cosa quello
schifo è una zampa a questa zona dopo
aver selezionato il livello di
difficoltà e iniziamo con un'altra
caterva di minigiochi il primo gioco e
prova l'osso come scusa prova l'osso non
l'ho capito prova l'osso ma ok ed è
semplicemente un click a caso per
cercare le ossa in modo che poi ci
togliamo sostegno
il secondo mini gioco e come quello di
twilight cioè ti fanno vedere una scena
di un film e tu devi rispondere alla
domanda che ti fanno subito dopo
beh era palesemente un furgone la
risposta giusta è furgone e si la
risposta giusta era furgone perché c'è
scritto autocarro su dvd
la risposta giusta è furgone doppiatore
mi confondi leve non capisco si
concentri che quando bisogna vincere poi
abbiamo il meno quiz e che sarà mai il
dinho quiz e un quiz sui dinosauri sono
stupefatto e se risponderei bene
congratulazioni ai ottenuto un dinosauro
me lo porto a casa bartolini in busta
chiusa e dulcis in fundo abbiamo il mio
preferito
salta il crepaccio devi decidere con
attenzione quando saltare sembra facile
ma capire quando saltare non è così
semplice soprattutto quando devono
premere invio nel mio telecomando che
non sono harry il cazzo è il tasto invio
ha esaltato troppo tardi
riprova la prossima volta a parte che
non è vero che ho saltato troppo tardi
ma poi non so qual è il tasto invio
sapete qual è il problema con questo
gioco qua e che ogni volta che sbagli
lui ti deve rifare daccapo l'intera
presentazione del gioco sudato per
riprovare un sotto che dura una frazione
di secondo madrid 20 morti e uscito
l'osso in pensare che appena fatto mai
ho sbagliato ho fatto un errore di
calcolo e anche perso ma basta st
presentazione basta che l'ultimo dvd gay
che voglio presentarvi oggi è il divo di
game che credo sia fatto apposta per
l'italiano medio non solo perché stai
col culo seduto sul divano a giocarci
con il telecomando in mano ma c'è anche
il fattore semi vi presento il gioco di
cultura moderna
il gioco ufficiale di cultura moderna
non vorrei mai che qui sviluppatori
della thailandia si mettesse a fare il
giorno di cultura moderna e in modo non
ufficiale infatti anche tu un po di
cultura moderna 10 divertentissimi
minigiochi i balletti originali di
giuliana per l'italiano medio che non
deve chiedere mai
ma il gabibbo ai rigori
no ma io voglio vedere i balletti di
giuliana
oh yeah
ma ciao teo mammucari base è ancora in b
fair dopo aver scelto la modalità di
gioco è il numero di giocatori
si parte decidi che vuoi indovinare se
un personaggio vip un personaggio
storico e poi si parte con la
masturbazione scimmiesca è proprio un
divertimento per tutta la famiglia
immagino tipo se si è seduto con la tua
ragazza con tua moglie quanto
divertimento ci sia nell'aria prima
prova trova il pezzo mancante della foto
o no non sono abbastanza stupido per
riuscire a giocare a questo gioco
seconda prova con un incubo in alto a
sinistra e chief warr i dal labirinto
poi abbiamo il classico vero falso ogni
volta che tu hai successo in un
minigioco teese bocca degli indizi che
ti aiuteranno poi a capire chi è il
personaggio storico il vip che devi
indovinare indice 1 ai capelli scuri
secondo indizio è famosa anche per la
chirurgia estetica a cui si è sottoposta
io dico maria de filippi o no era carmen
di pietro e questo sarebbe il momento
buono per andare accendere il gas in
cucina e sterminare tutta la tua
famiglia e anche parte della palazzina
ma abbiamo ancora una cosa vedere una
console che non è la console che pensavi
di ricevere signore e signori la mega
station
lo so che così sembra quasi un john tron
l'angri videogame nerd che non me
l'hanno regalata qua si avvicini
l'orecchio la scatola puoi sentire
proprio quella zia lontana ormai vecchia
che ti dice che ho comprato la
playstation 3
ti piace così puoi giocare ai giochi del
intendo con i fratini grazie zia è
quindi è console con giochi tv 8 bit
pistola flash
cosa vuol dire che fa vedere le tette
per strada presa scart di collegamento
inclusa the feature e ben 14 giochi
inclusi 11 con controller e tre con
pistola direi di provarla voi non avete
idea di quanto pesi questa cosa qua
questa cosa qua e aria solida colorata
di
per farvi capire meglio mi sono fatto
portare una bilancia da cucina
per farvi un esempio l'accendiamo questo
joypad e del ismo porca miseria questo
joypad polveroso dell'xbox juan che non
è uno dei più leggeri ma comunque
soltanto un joypad e pesa 278 g solo il
joypad pesa 278 g questa è la mega
station e tutta la mega station ne pesa
neanche 200 il joypad dell'xbox one pesa
70 grammi in più della console mega
station
se la console pesa così c'è io veramente
non so come farvelo vedere che vuoto
questo qui è vuoto 57 grammi
questo vuol dire che se tu metti la
console e il joypad insieme non arriva a
fare il peso del joypad e xbox o come
come funzionano e come funziona la mia
vita
l'idea quindi io direi di dargli
un'occhiata
ok questa è la schermata di selezione di
giochi e la scatola ha già detto la sua
prima bugia
i giochi non sono 14 sono leggermente di
più guarda per me va benissimo e ci
mettiamo tutta la notte qui però io li
vorrei vedere tutti partiamo dal primo
pupo pokémon c'è pokémon nella mega
station
cosa succede nella mia vita da quel che
ho capito questo dovrebbe essere il
clone di un altro gioco che di cui non
ricordo perchè sono forse un po troppo
giovane dove devi prendere delle mele
con pikachu per poi liberare un altro
più epico giu mentre se eseguito da un
terzo pica su una mega station sarà
leggero nel peso ma è pesante nell'animo
magari solo una mera ma non come giochi
da giocare con la pistola abbiamo da
kant tiro al piattello e basta ed ecco
la seconda bugia della scatola non solo
tra i giochi sono due con la pistola e
che è pistola da beretta pratica avrebbe
che pesa come una matita dell'ikea però
è che siccome i giochi con queste
pistole venivano fatti per essere
giocati nelle televisioni a tubo
catodico
come funzionerà sulla mia piatta alla
perfezione poi abbiamo soccer il gioco
di calcio della nintendo abbiamo galaxia
nel gioco da astronavi abbiamo gioco per
ogni genere praticamente abbiamo anche
il gioco di auto da quelli su cui mi
vorrei soffermare sono quelli di
supermario abbiamo super mario bros che
super mario bros
poi abbiamo long live mario che
semplicemente supermario che però parte
dal secondo mondo una scelta di
marketing azzardata ma che funziona
credo poi abbiamo mario mario dalla luna
supermario che però inizia dal terzo
mondo quello sai di di notte e quindi si
chiama dalla luna per quello e poi
abbiamo sensi mario scelsi mario e
supermario vagato nel senso che mentre
vai avanti ci sono dei bagni ci sono né
glitch grafici che ti fanno apparire
delle immagini sullo sfondo come si
stesse di creando un altro livello
dietro di te ma cosa porca di una
[ __ ] i miei occhi stanno guardando
fortunatamente ci sono altri 9 milioni
999.999 giochi circa così possiamo
passare il tempo in allegri
e volete sapere cosa sono quegli altri
giochi sono semplicemente varianti degli
stessi 14 giochi abili a c a d afp
z come giuro su dio che ne ho
selezionati alcuni non l'ho visto la
benché minima differenza con i 14
principali guarda starei ancora qui a
farmi trovare da una console che non
dovrebbe esistere nella natura nella
natura ma purtroppo è tardi ho un
appuntamento con la mia morte
quindi fatemi un favore si e nonne e
anche genitori un po anzianotti di tutto
il mondo regalate soldi ai vostri nipoti
ai vostri figli ma per l'amor di dio
fermiamo questo scempio
addio